- I essentially don't have a pulse.
You can check everywhere you'd want
and you won't feel a pulse.
So I'm pretty much the best
looking zombie you'll ever see.
(laughs)
My name is Andrew Jones
and I'm a professional
fitness model, living
with an artificial heart.
I always have to have batteries charging.
At night when I'm going to
bed, I'll plug my phone in
and then I'll plug myself
into the wall outlet
to make sure I have power overnight.
In 2012, I was diagnosed
with a cardiomyopathy
which affects the heart’s
efficiency to pump blood.
I was incredibly ill at the time
and I was admitted to
the ICU for four months
where they had to implant
what's called an LVAD,
which stands for Left
Ventricular Assist Device.
And it's considered an artificial heart.
It's taking over the
work of my heart for me.
These devices, the two
batteries and the computer,
these are what are
powering and controlling
the artificial heart, to make sure that
it's working efficiently
and working properly.
I started feeling strong
again when I was recovering
after having the
artificial heart implanted.
And, of course, it didn't all
come at once, I took baby steps
and I found myself back in
the gym sooner than later.
And I got my strength back
and once I'm able to find
the right match for a heart transplant,
I'll no longer need my artificial heart.
At first I was upset about
having an artificial heart
and then there was the
moment where I realized that
this is my life for now
and either I can dwell
and feel sorry for myself, or I
can continue doing the things
that I love to do, the best way
I can and I haven't stopped.
I'm proud of the scars that
I have from my surgeries
because scars are beautiful,
they're a part of you.
They tell your story and no one
can take that away from you.
(heart beating)